very soon afterwards
as ian dale who moderated many of these
hustings in 2019 said
i found sharing the husting is a
surprisingly positive experience
the members really put the two
candidates through their paces and asked
some very searching questions
so i ask you tonight to make your
questions searching
to make them succinct
and to ask questions and not to make
statements
so that more of the audience have an
opportunity to grill our candidates
both of our candidates have a duty and a
desire to fulfill our 2019 manifesto
their differences will be about how to
go about achieving that in a very
different world from 2019
post-brexit post-covert and uncertain
times internationally look at the
ukraine and taiwan
and where our union as a nation is being
challenged
so i'm sure that tonight you'll want to
test our candidates
to seek to establish their strengths and
to see who you think is best capable of
running our great country
and i know that as all of us are
conservatives here tonight you want to
be respectful of our two candidates and
keep your questions positive
there are now under two weeks left to
vote
if you haven't already voted then i ask
you to vote online or by post
and it's very easy to vote online
or you can choose traditional snail mail
but if you do post then please remember
to put a stamp on the envelope and that
there's planned postal strikes this
weekend so voting online is the way to
go
you should all by now receive your
ballot paper if you haven't then please
contact your constituency office we'll
be able to help you
so tonight my hope is
that you'll be given more clarity
about how to cast your vote
i hope that you'll go away enthused and
energized
in your commitment to helping our great
party win the next election
we need your support
finally i want to remind everyone
that at the end of our democratic
process
we must come together as a party
we have many new members who should be
contacted and made welcome we have
members return returning to the fold and
we must make use of their times
ours has to be a combined effort
under our new leader to go forward to
victory at the next election
so ladies and gentlemen without further
ado let's get on with the show
please welcome stevenson co-chair
[Applause]
thank you peter hello birmingham
hello
and hello to times radio listeners
tuning in to our west midlands
anyone who watched last month's
commonwealth games knows that you all
here can put on a show
and at least in this contest there's no
chance of you being beaten by the
australians
tonight is another event where you our
members have the chance of putting your
questions to our two great candidates
running to be the next leader of our
party
our hard-working party staff and myself
are remaining impartial during this
contest the choice is yours but we stand
ready to unite behind whoever you choose
as our next leader
that's what i've heard since my
appointment as part of chairman six
weeks ago meeting with party activists
up and down the country
including here in the west midlands
where so far i've been out campaigning
with
nicola richards and sean bailey in west
bromwich
marco longi and mike wood in dudley
[Music]
jonathan gullis jack branson and joe
gideon all in so-called trent
[Applause]
aaron bell in newcastle on the line
eddie hughes in warsaw
jane stevenson in wolverhampton
and wendy morton in eldridge
they are just some of the fantastic 42
hard-working conservative mps you helped
get elected here at the last general
election and i want to see them all
re-elected at the next general election
which by uniting behind your choice for
our next leader we can achieve just as
you helped get the amazing andy street
back in as the mayor of the west
midlands last year
and your choice whoever you choose will
be a brilliant leader both have shown
their qualities in government
demonstrating the drive and talent
needed to do the hardest job in britain
they will take us forward together
continuing the work done by our prime
minister boris johnson who has shown
that concerned government can rise to
the challenges of today
getting brexit done delivering the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe
protecting over 14 million jobs during
the pandemic and leading the world in
supporting ukraine and standing up to
putin
it's a truly historic record on which
our new leader can build
the alternative of course is labour
a party that voted against tax cuts for
low-income families against additional
investment in our nhs against protecting
our borders and tackling the vile people
smugglers
would labour have ever got brexit done
if sakia stammer had his way we'd still
be fighting a second eu referendum
and the only way he can enter downing
street is by promising nicola sturgeon a
second one on scottish independence
birmingham you deserve better and so
does britain
it is our next leader who will continue
to deliver for the british people
leading the way in standing up for our
ideals and our partners on the world
stage
uniting the country and this concerted
party
and on that note let me finish by
thanking times radio our partner for
tonight's hustings and handing over to
your host for this evening
john pena
well um a very good evening ladies and
gentlemen i'm going to see you all out
there this evening it is it is such a a
pleasure as well as an enormous
privilege to be here as the host for the
business end of consuming this evening's
events and let me also send a big
welcome to
times radio listeners the audience
listening to every word that i'm
speaking and that's going to be spoken
from this stage of the course of the
next the next couple of hours and i
mentioned that because i want to mention
and welcome our valuable audience but
also as a reminder of the significance
of this
event as if you needed reminder you are
not just in the course of these
remaining two weeks of the campaign
choosing your party leader you're
choosing our prime minister which puts
you in a position of enormous enormous
uh i suggest a certain amount of
privilege a former leader of your party
uh once said just a paraphrase slightly
never has so much been owed
by so many to so few now the time will
tell just exactly what you are owed for
the decision you're going to be taking
over over the next couple a couple of
weeks
but you have a remarkable extraordinary
responsibility on your hands the roles
you
play i'm interested at this very very
early stage of the evening because i
hate to let an audience get away with
only any occasion the just asked you
know how many of you have already cast
your votes
okay well i mean there's quite a few
still left to play for richie and elise
you've still got a game to play here
here this evening and uh i'll now say
let's get on i'm looking forward to
what's following the course in the next
couple of hours i hope you are too i
very very much hope that we can between
us play a constructive and useful role
and what is
an incredibly important time in the life
of the politics of our country
so let me now get on with it and hand
over straight away now to me the
candidates and campaigns on either side
of this conservative party leadership
contest i'll be talking to you again
shortly thank you very much indeed
thank you very much and good evening
birmingham what a great privilege
it is uh for me to be here tonight on
home turf
um we should
be under no doubt
friends
that these are tough
economic ties
there is a war on our continent and
vladimir putin is using energy
as a weapon in that war specifically
it is a way of attacking the people of
this great country
for the help that we are providing to
the brave people
of ukraine
who will look tomorrow
tomorrow celebrate
their cherished national independence
day and we will celebrate with them
we have
come together tonight
and we must stay together
to weather
the storms of high energy costs
and inflation
and of course
hold our nerve
through this winter
that is the united kingdom
doing our bit
in this war
every bit as important as providing the
military support and training to our
ukrainian brethren
this country
led the world in our response
to the illegal invasion of ukraine and
tonight
i have the privilege of introducing the
woman who is at the forefront
of that response
our foreign secretary
took on the difficult task of
sanctioning the oligarchs of going after
putin's cronies and standing up to his
ministers and i am proud to be
supporting her tonight
i have seen the extent of the challenges
that our country is facing my friends
i know
that tough decisions
are needed to protect hard-working
families and businesses here
in the west midlands and of course
across
our country against inflation
but now that i have my feet under the
desk in number 11 i have also seen first
hand
that more of the same
is not an option
as we go into the final stretch
of these hustings we need to come
together quickly
just as we did
in that vaccine rollout and of course
deliver for our great country the
british people
expect us to fix the nhs backlog they
expect us to make our streets safer with
police focused on tackling serious crime
and use our freedoms to unleash business
and growth
we need to win the next election and we
need to win against both labour and the
lib dems
and of course liz trust
is the candidate that can unite the
party unite the country against putin
and win that next election for us
i came to this country
at the age of 11
fleeing saddam hussein
britain has given me
everything and i don't take the task
of choosing its next prime minister
lightly nor should you
but never
never have i been more certain that i'm
making the right choice
liz is decent
honest
hard-working
and above all
understands the economics of growth
she does what she says she will do
that is why she has my vote thank you
[Music]
to win the next election we need to
deliver deliver and deliver for the
british people
i know that our country's best days lie
ahead
i'm a candidate with a clear vision for
your future who can drive change and get
things done
as trade secretary our negotiator deals
with allies like australia and japan
creating opportunities around the world
for british business and as prime
minister i will continue to deliver on
the opportunities of brexit
i will lead a government committee to
call conservative principles low taxes a
firm grip on spending driving greater
the economy and giving people the
opportunity to achieve anything they
want to achieve regardless of their
background
i will work day and night to lead a
party in government that puts more money
in your pocket and secures a better life
for you and your family
i've consistently delivered when i had
said i would
and i love our country
i want the best for us all
and i am the person
please welcome liz trust
it's fantastic to be here in birmingham
i'm not from a traditional conservative
background
i grew up in paisley in scotland
and in leeds where i went to the local
comprehensive school
what i saw at my school
is i saw
children who were let down
they were let down because of low
expectations because of their background
they were let down because of leed city
council caring more about political
correctness than making sure all
children learned english and maths
and they were let down because of a lack
of opportunity
in the area
and i thought that was an appalling
waste of talent
and i wanted things to be different
that's why i went into politics i want
everybody across a great country to have
opportunity regardless of their
background
i want us to be an aspiration
nation
and that is what
our fantastic mayor andy street is
delivering here in the west midlands
he's the lord on the fantastic
commonwealth games who is great to visit
a few weeks ago
he's delivered on the trams and the
metro
and he has delivered investment growth
and business into this fantastic part of
the country
and what i want to do as prime minister
is i want to help him and all of our
brilliant mps across the midlands
deliver more for people and open up
those opportunities and that aspiration
but the reality is we face difficult
economic times
we have the war in ukraine
we have the energy crisis and we have
the aftermath of kovic
and we've had several decades in this
country of low economic growth so we do
need to be bold
and we do need to do things differently
we can't just have more business as
usual we need a plan for growth
and that is what i would deliver as your
prime minister
first of all i will unleash the
opportunities of brexit
we need to get all of the eu law off our
statute books by the end of 2023
and that means
that means that we will unleash
investment into cities like birmingham
towns and cities across our country
we can do more trade deals benefiting
industries like ceramics industries like
the car industry and i had a great visit
earlier to jlr industries like financial
services and technology
but we also need to cut tax
i would reverse the national insurance
increase the fact is we didn't need to
increase national insurance we can still
afford to pay off the debt
i'll start paying off the debt after
three years i'd also have a moratorium a
temporary moratorium on the green energy
levy to immediately save people money
off their fuel bills
and i i keep corporation tax low
because if we raise our corporation tax
to the same level as france
and 10 points higher than ireland we
won't attract that new investment into
this part and other parts of our country
and i fundamentally believe as
conservatives we need to be on the side
of people who work hard and do the right
thing the self-employed the small
businesses commuters who go into work
every day that's inside
and i would legislate to make sure
essential services are being provided
like our railway services and we stop
the militant trade unions disrupting our
country
now before i was a member of parliament
i joined the conservative party back in
1996 i was a party activist and i was
also a local counsellor
and as a local counselor i sat on the
planning committee
and i'm afraid to say
i'm afraid to say those are hours of my
life i will never get back
because we were overruled by the
planning of spectra and bristol all the
top down housing targets so i would
immediately abolish the top down targets
in the planning bill coming up
and i would level up in a conservative
way
by creating new low tax investment zones
with the support of local mps local
mayors bringing investment into our
country
and what i would also do
is change the treasury rules about
investment so we're putting more of that
into the areas that don't have it
already not the areas that do have it
already
and i would also back
our fantastic farmers
i want our farmers producing food not
filling out forms and i want our fields
full of crops and livestock
not full of solar panels
we need to continue to stand up to
vladimir putin in ukraine
i'm proud that we were the first
european country to send weapons to
ukraine
and i as foreign secretary put the
toughest sanctions regime on russia of
any country in the world but we cannot
be complacent about our security
we need to make sure
that we are increasing our defense at
this insecure time and i would raise
defense spending to three percent of gdp
by the end of the decade
and i will also
crack down on illegal immigration
i supported it
i supported and worked with pretty patel
on the rwanda scheme we need to make it
work and we need to expand it to more
countries
what i would do is legislate to make
sure our decisions about our borders
cannot be overruled by the
hr
but as well as freedom and democracy
around the world
we also need it here in britain
we need free speech and we need to push
back against the identity politics of
the left
now
i'm a plain speaking yorkshire woman
and i know
that a woman is a woman
and i will i will make sure that we
protect our single sex spaces like
domestic violence shelters i'll also
stand up for the united kingdom i travel
around the world people respect us they
respect the role we have played in
democracy and freedom but there are too
many people in britain trying to talk
our country down saying we should
somehow be ashamed of our past that our
best days are behind us i don't agree
with those people our best days are
ahead of us
and we can see we can see what's
happening here
and how
andy street
is turbocharging and moving forward
birmingham
and in 2019
we won sways of seats right across the
midlands
places like stonehenge
west bromwich dudley north
people voted for us not because they
wanted their labour party they were fed
up with the labor party they were fed up
with the labour party letting their area
down what they wanted is conservative
values
personal responsibility
low taxation enterprise and opportunity
in their area and that's what we have to
deliver we have to get those spades in
the ground
we have to deliver on what we promised
in 2019 and i'm somebody that gets
things done
i don't take no from her answer
and
at the department of trade i delivered
dozens of trade deals where people said
it wouldn't be possible
at the foreign office i delivered the
northern ireland protocol bill two
parliament three white ball we got the
consent of the house and commons i'm
prepared to get things done
and take the tough decisions and that's
what we need
and that's what i will do
i will unleash the potential of our
great country if i am elected as your
prime minister
i will stand up
against kierstarma yet another labour
leader yet another labour party
politician who doesn't believe in
opportunity and doesn't believe in
aspiration
and i will help us and i will make sure
working with you that we win
the next general election and we keep
the west midlands blue thank you
liz thank you for that opening
contribution and this certainly seems to
be through beings as far as as i can see
and actually look at the opinion polls
just now i can understand this perhaps
being full of beings we're going to find
out between us in the course of this
this coming session whether liz trusts
and whether rishi sunak are equally full
of answers to questions and what when
what the
foreign went down very well with a large
section of this of this hall but i think
you all know because people listening to
this line also know there's a great deal
we haven't heard from these contenders
to be our prime minister about issues in
fact millions of us at this
extraordinarily difficult time hopefully
in the course of the next couple of
hours we will make some progress on that
as well so that's now without me taking
up too much time at this stage because i
will be back and serve with our
candidates let me carry on and hand over
to the
please welcome campaign of parliament
sutton goldfield andrew mitchell
[Applause]
well good evening everyone and welcome
to these hustings in britain's second
city which has just dazzled the world
with the most brilliant the most
successful commonwealth games ever held
and where we in the royal town of sutton
coalfield were so proud to hold the
triathlon
and as we come towards the end of these
major regional hustings please let me
say that both candidates to lead our
party and our country as prime minister
are brilliant
and don't you think as we look back to
the start of this contest
if you can remember that far back
and at the eight of my colleagues who
first stood for the leadership that it
is only the conservative party our party
which truly looks like and reflects the
country which we seek to serve and who
can doubt that either of them would be a
far better prime minister than kierstana
who until recently was supporting jeremy
corbyn to lead our country
now in the 35 years since i was first
elected to serve in the house of commons
no leader of our country has faced such
a daunting inheritance
nor acquired such courage
judgment and experience
it is as if all the threats and
challenges of the last 50 years are
being visited on us in one fell swoop
we face industrial disruption and an
energy price cycle with terrifying
household costs
interest rate and mortgage and rent
rises
warfare and crisis in europe and
inflation
with the devastation it causes as it
devalues us all
it was mrs thatcher who said
inflation is the parent of unemployment
and the unseen robber of those who have
saved
and that is all before
the huge issues for our health service
which arise from the coveted crisis and
its legacy
but ladies and gentlemen it is not
problems which defeat governments
it is the way we politicians and our
leaders defeat those problems which
determines our fate
and so it is in these circumstances
that i choose to support rishi sunak
as do some of our most respected former
party leaders michael howe and william
haye and
you may feel this is of particular
significance some of our most successful
finance ministers chancellors nigel
lawson ken clark norman lamont and peter
when faced with the unprecedented
challenge of coving and the massive
threat to jobs
and employment it was risky sunnah who
designed and implemented what the imf
described as the best fellow scheme in
the world and ensured through his
efforts that we protected the
livelihoods of 14 million people and the
future of one and a half million
businesses
and so
as we head into an extraordinary and
dangerous storm of frightening economic
ferocity it is rishi sunak who has shown
by his deeds and his actions that he is
the safe helmsman with the experience
record and judgment to weather these
storms to reach out across our divided
society
and to secure the results we need if we
are to win the next general election
we need a prime minister of courage
judgment
decency
and experience
that prime minister
is rishi soon
[Applause]
think smarter
underdogs don't give up
they'll do the difficult things and they
never ever get complacent
so
write them off if you like
sit back and dismiss him but if there's
one thing i know to be true
it's that britain loves an underdog
please welcome rishi sunak
[Applause]
thank you
thank you good evening thank you
now i am here tonight for one simple
reason and that's because our country
did something extraordinary for my
family like many of yours here it
welcomed them here as immigrants and
allowed them to build a better life
now i was raised with a few simple
values
first among those is that family means
everything to me
and that's because we know don't we as
conservatives that the bonds of family
are far greater than anything any
government could ever hope to replicate
and in my family
we prioritized hard work
as a way to forge ahead in life
my dad was an nhs gp
my mom ran the local chemist in
southampton where i grew up and i spent
all my time working in her shop
out and about delivering medicines to
patients but also doing her books and
seeing the power
of that small business to provide jobs
in our local community
now for my parents there was one thing
that they believed above all
would be the way to build a better
future for their three children and it
was simple
it was through education
and that's why today i passionately
believe
that the best way that we reduce
inequality the best way that we spread
opportunity indeed the best way that we
transform people's lives is by ensuring
that the birthright of every child is a
world-class education
patriotism
family
hard work
service and i know as i saw you know
those are your values too and that's
because they're conservative values and
that's why i want to be your prime
minister to put those values into action
to build a better britain
[Applause]
but how are we gonna do that well we
need to do three things
first we must restore trust
next we need to rebuild the economy
and then
we need to reunite our country
now when it comes to restoring trust for
me
that starts with honesty
and as you can see in this leadership
race i have not chosen to say the things
that people may want to hear
i have said the things that i believe
the country needs to hear
and even though
that doesn't make my life easy it is
honest and for me that is what
leadership is all about
but will also restore trust by
delivering on the things that matter to
people that's why i've set out a plan to
start reforming the nhs
so we can stop constantly thinking about
throwing more money at it and more talk
about the efficient healthcare that
we're getting out of it
it's why i want to take on this lefty
woke culture that seems to want to
cancel our history
and our women
and
it's what i want to make sure
that we keep our communities and streets
safe so it is remarkable that right here
we have a labor police and crime
commissioner who seems to be spending
more of his time trying to find ways to
make it easier for people to take
illegal drugs rather than actually
tackling crime i tell you this
for me whether it comes to using things
like stop or search or indeed tackling
grooming gangs i will never let
political correctness stand in the way
of keeping us safe
and whether whether whether it is that
labor policing crime commissioner or
indeed the shambles that is sandwell
council it just shows why we need
conservatives conservative councillors
conservative pccs and great conservative
mayors like andy street in charge
but it's also why i want to restore
trust in our rural communities like mine
in north yorkshire like yours here
in morata and staffordshire derbyshire
nottinghamshire and that means
increasing our food security protecting
our agricultural land and unequivocally
backing british farmers
and
it's why
it's why i sell out a detailed and
radical plan to finally get to grips
with illegal migration
now i stand here
as a product of our country's proud
compassionate history in welcoming
people to our shores
but it must be done legally it must be
done fairly and we where we turn on our
tv screens and see the scenes of people
breaking the rules to come here it
undermines trust in the system and it is
wrong and we must stop it with my plan
we will and we will get control of our
borders
now when it comes to rebuilding the
economy you all know that the number one
challenge is inflation inflation is the
enemy
it makes everyone poorer
it eats into people's hard-earned
savings their pensions
it pushes our mortgage rent
now
this autumn winter i will make sure that
we support people with the cost of
living
not only cutting vat on energy bills but
going further to help the most
vulnerable in our society
like those on the lowest incomes and
pensioners because that is what the
compassionate conservative government
must do at a time like this
but what what ladies and gentlemen what
i will not do what i will not do is
pursue policies that risk making
inflation worse and last in far longer
especially if those policies amount to
borrowing 50 billion pounds
and putting it on the country's credit
card and then asking our kids and our
grandkids to pick up the tab because
that is not right
now i will i will
cut your taxes but i will do it
responsibly by being tough on public
spending and by growing our economy and
that's why this autumn i'm going to
radically change how we tax businesses
in this country
cutting taxes for those businesses that
are doing the right thing investing and
expanding their production businesses
that are innovating to create the
products and services of the future
because that is how you drive growth in
a modern economy and the businesses that
will benefit the most will be those
manufacturing businesses right here in
the midlands
but it's also as someone as someone who
was proud to support brexit we need to
make sure that we capitalize on it and
that means we must get on with cutting
eu red tape
and as chancellor
i've created a new brexit policy of
freeport and put one right here in the
midlands
it's wise tom answer i invested in new
institute of technology here transport
infrastructure in communities up and
down in stoke in wolverhampton in dudley
in mansfield and ashfield i was a
chancellor who delivered for the
midlands and i will be a prime minister
who continues leveling up here in the
midlands
because in two years
when it comes to reuniting our country
we have to do something that has never
been done before
we have to make british political
history
by winning a fifth general election in
iraq
now even though that hasn't been done i
know that working together all of us we
can do it
but it's going to require us to appeal
to swing voters everywhere
right here
in the north in the south in liberal
areas and labour areas in
remain areas in brexit areas in urban
areas and rural areas in wales and in
scotland and i passionately believe and
the evidence suggests that i am the
candidate that offers our party the best
opportunity
of beating labour and ensuring kirstalva
never walked through the doors of number
10 down the
and in street let me just say this you
saw me as chancellor
at the beginning of a pandemic acting
radically
to successfully safeguard our economy
through the biggest economic
in 300 years
now as your prime minister i promise you
i will apply that same urgency and grip
to every other aspect of government to
build a better britain a britain
where our kids can walk safely on the
streets at night a britain where the nhs
is finally reformed and there for us
when we need a britain where our schools
and apprenticeships are the envy of the
world in providing opportunity
and britain where our economy is the
most dynamic it has ever been with our
businesses investing and innovating to
create jobs in every part of our country
but i also promise you this
perhaps more importantly
that i will give you my all
to ensure that each and every one of you
here tonight
can always feel enormously proud
of the conservative government that i
will be privileged to lead
so i humbly ask for your support
not just to be your next party leader
but also the next prime minister of our
great country thank you
[Music]
well that was punchy
i believe it was a perfect neutral i
think i have to pay tribute to the
energy of the uh and the force and the
word perfect nature of that presentation
the uh the camping videos is like
watching a holiday hollywood opening
this evening and so we'll carry on now
because
as i mentioned earlier on i think we
know now a certain amount
about these two contenders to be uh
prime minister and i think no one in the
whole community deny there's an awful
lot we do not know an awful lot that we
want and that goes for people in this
hall in the conservative party and many
many more outside so if i can do
anything and we do anything between us
to make something of a
dance in that in that in that uh that
vacuum of information uh and all of the
rest of it let's tell you i want to
start now by welcoming if you would to
the stage foreign
[Applause]
it's good to see you please um you look
very
very fast you're very confident and i
can look into these opinions i can quite
see where that might be the case but um
there's an awful lot i'd like to ask you
a quick bit more than i get to ask for
the time available to me and we all have
this evening here at this 10th of 12th
house in the locals of this cafe so let
me start there with something which is
that you'll know this
very much on the line of millions of
people out there today
the
latest forecasts for inflation
are
terrifying
at the end of this week we'll get a
number the latest number for the energy
price cab
we expect something 3500 or something
north of that there's talk of of the
cost of borrowing
in the city maybe going up to seven
percent i could go on but it all adds up
to fear and legitimate fear and worry in
the hearts of so many people now you
haven't quite said so but somehow by
some curious
means between your camp and people like
we mean our clearance there will be
um a special budget statement if you're
the prime minister um towards the
back end of september um first of all
you can confirm that i've no doubt and i
know you're not going to give me the
detail of that thing i'm not going to
even try and force details of that out
you'll tell me i just spared you and now
sometime i know that you want to leave
some leeway for your next chancellor
when you get into the into the goblet
one thing you can tell us now
because you are bidding to become first
lord of the treasury
at the pinnacle of our office of this
coming government under whoever the
prime minister happens to be you believe
it's you the pollsters seem to agree
with you so can you tonight can you now
reassure
those who are worse off in our country
those pensions poor pensions people on
benefits people in most need that in
that coming budget sacredly which you
may or may not call a budget
they will be fully protected from at
least the effects of the coming rises in
energy bills which will be far greater
than anyone imagined
well look we are facing very very
difficult economic times and this is a
crisis that's been brought on by covered
by the war in ukraine and that is why
it's so vital we stand up to vladimir
putin but we've got another issue that i
would add to all this job which is the
issue of low economic growth and the
danger of a recession and we know that a
recession would carry a huge toll
and we also need to make sure the
economy is growing so we have multiple
challenges that we face as a country and
this is why we have to be bold and i
have set out a bold agenda i'm not just
lowering taxes and helping people who
are struggling and i understand
there are problems with food bills
bills with fuel bills but also with the
cost of living we also need to make sure
we grow the economy and we avoid talking
ourselves into a recession i think
that's very important taxes are
currently at a 70-year high and there is
a current proposal to raise corporation
tax which i believe would deter
investment and make it harder for us to
grow the economy so we have multiple
challenges the will needs to be
a fiscal event as you rightly say and
i've set out my priorities my first
priority is reducing taxes because what
i don't believe is taking money from
people with taxes and then giving it
back to them in benefits that is more
than brand economics
is supply and in particular the energy
supply we haven't done enough to get
gas out of the ground to use our
reserves to move forward with nuclear to
move forward renewables we need to get
on with those things much quicker as
well as liberating other bits of supply
of the economy i talked in my speech
about investment you know we need to do
things like solvency before we liberate
investments so we need to deal with the
supply
now of course in any physical event a
chancellor has to look at
people on fixed incomes and i've already
committed to
the triple lock for pensioners i've
already committed to
a temporary moratorium on the green
energy levy which will take money off
everybody's fuel bills but as you
rightly say
we are not going to sit here today john
and write
write the budget but what i fear has
been missing from the economic discourse
is first of all
dealing with
growth
and getting growth going because without
growth we are in an even
[Applause]
policies
to to carry out these these unfunded tax
cuts in over stimulating growth your
critics say that's a room to hire
information which would hurt everyone
including the worst of michael gove says
you're on a holiday from reality can you
give your critics an example a clear
example of where our country has
successfully ruined its economy through
cutting taxes because without that
aren't you inviting the country to join
you on that experiment and experiment
with people's lives and lives i'll give
you the example of britain where we cut
corporation tax and we saw revenues
increase
there's an example of where cutting
taxes actually helped us attract more
revenue into the treasury and more
growth into the economy this this whole
language john of unfunded tax cuts
implies the static model the so-called
abacus economics that the treasury
orthodoxy has promoted for years but it
hasn't worked for our economy because
what we've ended up with is high tax
high spending and low growth and that is
not a sustainable model for britain's
future
i i raise my issues internally i've
complained about plenty of these
policies internally but i respect
collective responsibility and i was
loyal throughout but fundamentally it
was wrong to raise national insurance we
promised we wouldn't do it in our
manifesto we didn't need to do it we
could have funded the nhs costs out of
general taxation and that decision was
taken i think it's wrong because we now
have their highest taxes in 70 years
we're talking about putting our
corporation tax up to the same level as
france last time i looked france was not
a low tax country we need to compete
internationally
we need businesses like jlr in midlands
to attract the investment in to create
those high paid jobs and
i can give you plenty of examples of
economies and very much
are you now invited
with margaret thatcher
i believe
every
[Applause]
woman women
in 1979 it's a different situation and
we need different policies now but the
principles she believed in were the
right principles enterprise personal
responsibility giving people control
over their own money putting money back
in people's pockets those are the
principles i agree with the tax burden
was higher when margaret thatcher left
office that it was when he took office
now you say your strategy converts your
diverse recession in this country the
bank of england is predicting recession
over the space of five courses
starting this year are you saying you
can stop that you can roll that back
because that is a huge promise and you'd
be judged by it by the earth
what i'm saying
is that a forecast isn't destiny that we
have the ability to change our own
future by doing things differently and
this is why we need to be bold and i see
huge opportunities you know one of the
things we're talking about here in the
midlands is the gigafactory that's an
exciting opportunity we need to attract
that investment you know we're talking
about huge things like life sciences
technology financial services we can
unlock those opportunities now i'm not
foolish enough to get out of crystal
ball and say i can predict what the
level of growth in the economy will be
this year and next year and by the way
nobody else can either but what i know
is putting up taxes to
the highest level in 70 years will choke
off that potential growth that's what i
know i'm a conservative i believe in low
taxes i believe in companies succeeding
i believe in companies making profits
that they are able to hire new workers
and bring in investment and that is what
i believe and that's the platform i'm
standing on
so our public
public
just the latest headline dominating the
news today about the awful a crime in
liverpool where an eight-year-old girl
was killed by a gunman forcing their way
into her home what does that say what
would you say about that case and what
it tells you is that someone pretended
to be prime minister about the need to
strengthen law enforcement
providing more police officers in
particular you may tell me there's a
promise for 20 000 more police officers
i will then tell you that's simply
making up for the cuts increased numbers
under conservative rule
do you say from those people who want
more
die about crying
first of all my thoughts go out to the
family and it's an absolutely
appalling crime and they're calling
um
murder murder that took place in
liverpool yes we do need to see more
police on our streets i mean we do it's
about recruiting more officers but it's
also about making sure those officers
are focused
on the crimes we care about the public
care about i would introduce the tables
so the public have a better way of
looking at how their local force is
performing and you know we need that
change in the culture
driven by
the police and crime commissioners
driven driven from the top
there is a serious problem in this
country with gunfire you know there's a
serious problem with gangs there's a
serious problem with knife crime and i'm
absolutely determined if we get a grip
of that okay then we all see now about
integrity
in government this is uh spurred by a
question from about time
listeners who wants to know and suggest
that there hasn't been enough said about
the need to improve conduct in
government given the grossest
circumstances of the foreign prime
minister would you appoint an ethics
advisor in place of the ethics advisor
who's resigned after the previous ethics
advisor who's resigned just as important
when you give that advice the power
to initiate investigations into
misconduct whether you want that
investigation or not
well first of all i do think there need
to be
proper whistleblowing procedures you
know i would put in place if i was
elected as prime minister a strong chief
whip i would return them to number 12
downing street so they they are at the
heart of government and making sure that
there is zero tolerance for misbehaviour
but
i do think one of the problems we've got
in this
in this country and the way we approach
things is you know we have numerous
advisors and independent bodies and
rules and regulations for me it's about
understanding the difference between
right and wrong and i'm somebody who is
always active with integrity
i've always
been clear about what i will do and
follow through on my promises and be
honest about the situation and that is
what i would do as prime minister i
don't think you can outsource
essays
i'm not i'm not i'm not
necessarily saying that but what i am
saying
is the leadership themselves the prime
minister themselves needs to take
responsibility and you cannot outsource
ethics to an advisor we need ethics
running through the government
and that's what's important to me and of
course i'll ensure that correct
apparatus is in place so that people are
able to
you know whistle blow if there are
problems but it is a leader is saying
that they don't know the difference
between right and wrong and they need to
outsource it to an ethics advisor i
think that's a fundamental problem
[Applause]
the floor fought in your character that
you would like to address and improve
um
i think some of my friends might say i'm
a bit relentless
[Music]
me and some conservative friends started
the conservative tenants and landlords
forum
and given the average millennial has
moved on average about 10 times what
would you do to reduce the number of
unnecessary moves and more broadly what
will you do for tenants and landlords
well first of all
i think it is important that we support
tenants and landlords and have a very
clear rental market and i also think
it's important that we date
so drive landlords out of the market and
we do make sure
that you know there are fair rules in
place but i also want to help more
people who've been renting get onto the
property ladder so what i would want to
do
is enable people with good rental
histories to be able to use those rental
histories to get a mortgage to help more
people own their own homes
[Applause]
hello miss
um i'll share one thing with you in that
i also grew up in paisley but many years
before you i'm not sure about that
we have now had a majority conservative
government for 12
in those years years the country seems
to have got even less conservative
we have we had to endure damaging wokery
in academia the civil service and even
the armed forces
what specific action would you take to
put that right
well i think i think we have achieved
many things
in our time in government i'm proud of
the education reforms that we delivered
which have improved schools i'm proud of
the welfare reforms that we've delivered
that have got more people into work but
you are right
there is an issue with the culture
in our public services not reflecting
the views of the public
and
this is true when it comes to talking
down our country
which i'm concerned about but it also is
true when it comes to women's rights and
i'd be very clear for example that i
will make sure that single sex spaces
are protected and we can't have a
situation where you know there are
hospital wards that claim to be single
sex that simply aren't
or we have domestic violence shelters
where that's under question but what it
takes is it takes political leadership
and it takes a prime minister that makes
that happen but also ministers that make
that happen in in departments and i
think as conservatives somehow sometimes
we've been afraid of making conservative
arguments
and we've allowed the left to dominate
the social space and i won't allow that
to happen i am prepared to make the
argument i am prepared to be difficult
i'm not prepared to make no for an
answer i'll get those things done
[Applause]
was the uk's first small business
commissioner there are six million small
businesses in the uk um i spoke to about
two thousand of them over the period two
years and i have to tell you they often
feel unloved over-regulated and
overtaxed
what can we do to promote long-term
business growth because that's the
backbone
[Applause]
so first of all reversing the national
insurance increase will help small
businesses that have been hit with extra
employers national insurance we also
need to look at the regulatory burden on
businesses i will conduct or i would
conduct a full tax review looking at
things like business rates and how we
make that much much fairer for small
businesses but we also need to look at
regulations and the regulatory burden
this is part of the point of getting all
of those eu laws off the statute books
by the end of 2023 because it often
isn't an individual law
it's just a combination of falls that
businesses are asked to fill in and the
peeps they're asked to jump through and
it's easy for a big business with a big
hr department with a big tax department
to do that work it's very hard for small
businesses so i will absolutely make
sure i'm cracking down on those
regulations but also we're not putting
new regulations on small businesses
some of our biggest businesses are
formerly public utilities little
questions
about those let me just ask the briefly
about
water industry we're seeing daily
reports now of pollution fouling our
waterways and coastline of this of this
country and meanwhile i think average
purposes to
execute the water companies are at 670
000 pounds
that can't be right
i do think there are problems with the
way
utilities are regulated we were one of
the first countries to regulate
utilities and to privatize utilities but
the world has moved on since then and
what tends to happen over time as some
of those regulators get mission creep
they don't necessarily
keep the market as
you know
properly as they should and i certainly
think it's the case that water companies
need to be better at stopping leaks they
need to be better at dealing with
pollution
and we need to sort that out so i do
agree more action needs to be taken by
the regulator you you can't fund it to
the environment agency
i am a great believer in value for money
from public services and believe me
there are plenty of things the
environment agency were doing that they
shouldn't have been doing and i was i
was very clear
that
i'm sure there are a few people in the
arena who have experienced the activity
environment agency
it's the responsibility of off what the
water regulator to be regulating on
on the way the water companies behave
that is off what's responsibility and we
should be putting that pressure on
[Applause]
i'm the them director for cpf
how are you thank you um how do you
ensure that your policy team regularly
engages with the cpf and our 10 000
members with our great grassroots policy
ideas and also given your drive for an
aspiration nation as a speech and
language therapist i'd like to ask how
will you ensure that education really is
a ladder opportunity for our children to
send and reduce the adversarial tribunal
culture around accessing the ehcp
support that these children need
so
so first of all
you know i joined the conservative party
in 1996.
i've been in conservative activists for
many years i've been a counsellor and
conservative members have huge value to
add and we need to be using them more in
government i would appoint a strong
single party chairman who would show
leadership on these issues as well as
making sure we are getting the policy
feed-in from the conservative policy for
them and also the feedback because one
of the mistakes i think we've made in
government is not listening enough to
people on the ground and i know
there's a huge amount of experience and
common sense right across the
conservative party and i'm somebody who
does engage with people who does talk to
people and i would absolutely commit to
do that on the issue of um
you know special educational needs
the system at the moment is pretty
difficult from parents and i speak to
parents you say they feel like they're
constantly battling the system and
actually if you are looking after a
child with special educational needs you
deserve
help
you don't deserve to have to battle the
system so we do need to reform the
system to make it much more responsive
to people i think family hubs are part
of the solution to that i think having
more support in schools is part of the
solution to that but i agree with you at
the moment we have created i'm afraid a
nightmare for lots of parents who have
to just battle the system
[Applause]
insurance
what will you do about the crisis
is to assume much of a stretch to use
that word about social care in this
country
how would you solve the problems facing
social care which are truly immense
so i i still would spend the money i
would just take out of general taxation
rather than raising national insurance
but i would spend that money in social
care the fact is quite a lot of it has
gone into the nhs i believe it should go
to local authorities to deal with the
very real issues in social care because
the problem we've got at the moment is
people are in beds in the nhs who would
be better off in social care beds so put
the money into social care
free up more space in the national
health service and empower the front
line in the national health center
because there are still too many central
dictats going to the front line people
on the front line feel disempowered
we're seeing increasing numbers of
people leaving the profession so those
are the issues we need to deal with
these services are styled with funds now
that you are proposing
we put these extra money in we put the
extra 13 billion in and what people who
work in the nhs tell me
is the problem is
the number of layers in the organization
they have to go through to get things
done the lack of local decision making
that's what people are telling me
that's what people are telling
um
young people who talk about youth
violence scan crime
and we're working at 38 primary schools
in the in the region right now kids are
at risk of getting involved in youth
violence
what do you perceive to be the
fundamental issues the root cause of
those problems and what would your
government do to bring some
transformation to those issues and
change the lives of some people
the work you do is very important and
you know i think
um youth clubs for example like houston
are very important in
giving
young people alternative places to be
rather than being praying for gangs
i visited one very recently in london
so i'd like to see more of those some of
those are funded by the private sector
others funded by the voluntary sector
i support schools opening for longer
hours actually
again to
help help children get the skills they
need but also to make sure that they are
less preyed to
potential alternatives and i think it is
all about early intervention
that is what it's about it's about
making sure
the alternative is better for those
young people and they have those
opportunities and that's why
these things which sometimes sound
esoteric like talking about economic
growth what it is about is about more
apprenticeships more jobs more good
opportunities for young people so they
are not encouraged to
go off in the wrong direction
[Applause]
uh these weren't planted questions by
the way and we know that
working white class boys are actually
our most disadvantaged group uh both you
and rishi have mentioned education
aspirations
will you as conservative bring
background schools because
yes i will allow new grammar schools
absolutely
[Applause]
schools to expand and set up more
branches right around the country and
i'm somebody who did gave some
compensation school my daughters now
both go to grammar school i want
children all across the country to have
those opportunities but we also need to
deal with primary school education
because the fact is 30 of kids are
leaving primary school without basic
english and maths and it's very hard if
you get to age 11 without that
to be able to succeed in life it just
makes it a whole lot harder
you know
i'm proud of what i did in education i
removed calculators from the primary
school tests so that all kids had to get
the basics of mental arithmetic but we
need to do more because we need more
specialist teaching or particularly on
maths in primary school we need more
early years support too because the
earlier we style the
[Applause]
a question which is as better about you
this trust as it is about the increasing
policy so
your character and by the way when it
comes to you your personality i did
enjoy your interview on sunday
newspaper quite recently when you you
told the interviewer that you whenever
you see a mouse there were lots of mice
at the house you jump on a chair was
that true
i'm not sure if that interviews recently
but
i'm worried that somebody will get a
mouse out now
[Laughter]
[Applause]
10 so if i do become prime minister at
least i'll be my spree
that's too much of a match carrying
myself
now look here's another question one of
the first things
boat county or whether you prime
minister blizz trust
is giving the order to unleash our
nuclear weapons it will mean global
annihilation i would ask you would you
press a button you will say yes but
faced with that task i would feel
physically sick
how does that thought make you feel
i think it's an important
duty for the prime minister i'm ready to
do that
thank you for those answers
okay we don't have a platform so that
was reasonably encouraging for this i
think our next our next uh speaker
hopefully we find a lot of popularity in
this room as well ladies and gentlemen
please welcome rishi sooner
[Applause]
it's good to see you richie thank you
for good let me ask you a question for
us the first same question i took to you
as a liz trust
you know you know the numbers eighty
percent forecast of inflation the the
energy price gap is going up there are
far more than you imagine when you set
out that plan to help the worst off
which means to help the worse off in
future you will have to be much more
open handed with the british taxpayers
money will you do that can you guarantee
now if you are the prime minister you
will match whatever the need happens to
be as we head towards energy capsule
3500 maybe five six thousand in april
whatever it takes you will provide the
cash
yes and that's because the right thing
in these circumstances
is as i said for a compassionate
conservative government
to meet the needs of the most vulnerable
in our society and that's what i would
do as prime minister now
how are we going to do that as i said i
want to cut vat off energy bills because
that will provide some support to
everybody uh on top of what i announced
is nasa but there are two groups of
people for whom
i think we will need to go further that
suppose on the lowest incomes and
pensioners now my view is that the right
way to help those people is to provide
them with direct financial assistance
over the autumn of winter and
this is you as you probably discussed
is very different right and this is a
good point of debate in this conference
that's why these these customers are
doing a good forum
because this view is that
we've ruled out providing direct support
and takes the tax cuts for the officer
now
the tax cut that she's proposing for
someone on her salary is worth about 1
700 pounds right that's pretty hefty for
someone working very hard on the
national living wage
that tax cut is worth barely a pound a
week
for a pensioner who's not working there
are millions of those who are very
anxious about winter that tax cut is
worth precisely zero
now i think if we carry on with that
plan if i don't win this and that's a
plan that we carry on with as a party
millions of people
are going to face a risk of destitution
this winter literally millions
and if we don't do anything to avert
that i think it will be a moral failure
of the conservative government and i
don't think the british people would
ever forgive us and if i'm prime
minister i will not let that happen
you changed your mind on on that why did
you do that you sir was it that you
suddenly feel rather more desperate to
win the support of people like these
conservative members it's because as you
said in your opening job the situation
has deteriorated since i was transferred
and announced support and i'm perfectly
open and blunt about that that coloring
beat is not the most perfect way to do
things it definitely has drawbacks but
you have to deal with the world as it is
if i become prime minister in a couple
weeks time and bills go up in just a few
weeks after that there aren't that many
levers that you can pull that deliver
support to almost everybody in the
country which is what you would need to
do that will actually work now i've been
there i've done the job right i've sat
there and figured out how you do this it
is one of the few lemurs that a prime
minister has available to them that i
know will 100
certainty get cash to people quickly is
it perfect no but i'm not going to let
pervert be the enemy of the good i'm
going to deal with the practical reality
of the situation so i don't make any
apology for going further than i said
before i want to make sure we help
people and that is a realistic practical
way to do it and i
[Applause]
you are against unfunded tax cuts
in principle not just as a matter of
economic theory which is of course i
guess why you said yesterday clearly i
guess as you could that you could not
serve in at least trust
no i mean what i was saying i'm not
focused on those
and
actually having been in canada i'm one
of these people who maybe it's
old-fashioned actually in the last few
weeks i've discovered quite how
old-fashioned it is my general view is
if you're in a cabinet while you're in
it uh and you you defend all the
decisions that's what collective
responsibility means and i take that
seriously i know it seems a bit quaint
so
and you know there's been a lot of talk
in this legion of election about
margaret thatcher and you know and
rightly so because she's our greatest
post-war prime minister but i reflect on
it and i think well what you know what
actually was margaret thatcher's most
important legacy why is it that she's so
revered now you could say was because
she took on the unions because of her
economic performance because she spread
homeownership far and wide now all those
things were important but i don't
actually think that's fine she's revered
i think it's because of her character
and she was prepared always to take
difficult decisions she was prepared to
say the things that might be difficult
that the country needed to hear she
wasn't prepared ever to make a promise
that she couldn't keep that's what i
think margaret was about and that's a
standard that i hold myself to and i
think unfunded tax cuts are wrong and
you know what
her chancellor either lawson agrees with
me the head of her policy unit agrees
with me norman lamont agrees with me all
these people who understood margaret
thatcher's economics are supporting my
economic plan because it's the right one
for our country and it's a conservative
approach to managing the economy and
that's what our party stands for
[Applause]
the rest of it now
when the sun comes there would have to
be votes in the house of commons on that
they'd have to be a finance bill and
those books are whipped three nine weeks
descent is not tolerated you wouldn't
serve an academy and defend those
policies would you vote for them i
time and i'm going to spend every minute
i've got tonight talking to the you know
1500 people that are here as i'm doing
every day five or six times a day
talking about members across the country
because you're acting like this is
already over and it's not i'm gonna
fight hard for every vote
[Applause]
many people today crying in the light of
the the awful news story that i
mentioned earlier on the eight-year-old
child in liverpool gunned down by ghana
who forced their way into the family
flat your thoughts on that and in the
context of the needed amount for more
police officers that have been proposed
now
the numbers we've seen so far is make up
the cuts from the austerity years what
would you do in office
i
uh about it earlier this evening
olivia i think uh her name was i
actually thought she was if she was nine
she's the same age as my
younger daughter and a terrific yeah i
before the pair of grandparents
is what i did when i found out about
earlier on uh today and and my heart
goes out to our family as i'm sure it
does from everybody here tonight uh
about grappling with the loss like that
you know what what can we do
you know government to try and prevent
things like that from happening yes it's
about putting more kids officers on the
street and
we've got a plan to do that but it's
also making sure that
well i mean at the moment we need to
finish putting 20 000 more on the
streets but i think actually we need to
make sure they're focused on the right
things and that we're using their time
effectively and we're using the best
techniques that are available to
policing and i mentioned it in my my
remarks earlier i think actually when i
talk to people involved in fighting
crime when i talk to our police and
crime commissioners and our counselors
everywhere you know what's clear is that
there are things that hold us back from
going to grips with crime in our country
and a couple of examples you know one is
stop and search which is a very
effective policing tool now you know our
concern with peace and crime
commissioners understand that they want
to use it we just came from the
hustlings of manchester where you know
andy burns the labour mayor has got
force has been special measures and i
want to actually provide police forces
like that with the powers to use stop
and search similarly i mentioned
grouping gangs and you know i think it's
another thing that has affected young
children
as young as olivia are my daughters for
too long it's very pervasive in our
country and if i'm fortunate to win this
i want to do something to tackle that
pernicious crime and as i said earlier i
will never let political correctness
stand in the way of keeping our country
isn't it to uh to charge patients
penalties when they fail to attend for
their medical appointments so let me put
it to you for the sake of of the
discussion
that's a gimmick who will enforce these
penalties are you proposing county court
actions they pursue 10 pounds 12 pound
penalties are you asking gps to delight
some people who can't or won't pay this
penalty how does it make sense so you
what
would you describe as a commitment i
completely and utterly disagree with it
right now we will we all as
conservatives know that we don't measure
our success by how much money we throw
at things and if we want to be able to
credibly cut taxes and i do i want to
cut all your taxes but there is no one
who can sit here
and credibly tell you that they're going
to cut your taxes responsibly unless
they've also got a plan to reform the
nhs to make it more efficient because if
we don't if we don't it will continue to
gobble up every single pound that
everyone has right and it's not enough
just to say that and say oh gosh yes i
was too many bureaucrats from the nhs
great like we're using practical
solutions right so yes this is one
because you know what 15 million
appointments last year
not not just the gp's but let's just go
let's come up with why this is a prize
for people to go after not just at gps
but hospital doctors do 15 million right
that's not right doesn't value our
doctors deprives people of the care they
need and if we can get this right it's
about making money from charging it's
about changing the culture in this
country so it's not acceptable
if we get it right
if people cancel those appointments in
advance then we free up tons of extra
healthcare and
we will get backwards down quicker
right so you know what i was the person
who
set up furlough in a matter of weeks
right when everyone said to me well how
would you do this how will this work we
don't even know what the word means let
alone how we're going to administer our
system that
is going to actually make sure we pay
the wages of 10 million people and every
single newspaper they told me afterwards
it kept space
that day to write the story that the
system would never work
and it did because that's what i do john
when they come across difficult problems
i get equipped with them i solve
[Applause]
but we believe that's across the
have signs up now don't they they all
have signs up but they tell you how many
people missed an appointment last week
last month because they don't want
people to miss appointments because it's
not valuable
all right um just a question
his name is william he's asking why
there's more focus on standards of
conduct
would your government be more honest
than the one we have yes
that's why i left the government
[Applause]
with the power
to initiate the investigation whether
you want them or not yeah i've said
already very clearly that i would
reappoint the independent advisor
and i would make sure they have the
powers and responsibilities to hold
people to account but
obviously it gets set by the leader and
i would set an example but i talked
earlier about appealing to swing voters
so i think this is really important now
we're going to win that election right
we're going to appeal to all these swing
voters that we need to
remember they're not they're not
tourists right every day they're not
labor people they're swim voters so
they're not ideological what do they
want they want a government that works
properly right that's what those people
want and my view is we need to build
them so i'm going to run a government
where things are conducted
seriously but they're conducted
competently with decency and integrity
at the heart of everything that we do
that is the change that i'm going to
bring that's the prime minister that i'm
going to be and that's how we're going
to restore standards and women
[Applause]
would you seem to change the system of
electing leaders of the conservative
party
it's worth people sitting down and
figuring out what worked what didn't
work talk to all of you uh about whether
how it worked for you i think that's a
totally reasonable thing to do but i
think i should go further than that
because we talk a lot on all these
things about what you know i want to do
for the country but i also care about
all of you and if you've got five
minutes tonight if you're interested
online somewhere there is my contract
with members
because i think all of you are amazing
right i'm over here because of the
support of my association my activists
my volunteers my counselors and we owe
all of you an extraordinary debt so with
my contract for members i've sent out a
few things that i want to do to support
all of you i'll give you two things just
to throw it out there but one of them i
i really thought
about it i want to regularly make sure
we have surveys of what you think i
should have to go to conhold and see
what you think i want to know what you
think directly and and more than that
more than that
what i want to say is
what i will commit to is we're going to
have these regular surveys and then
those top issues are they're going to
get actually discussed at our political
cabinets so that you can join this party
one week you can feel in your ideas next
week and know that it's going to be
discussed by the people at the top the
week after that because that's how a
party like ours should work and the
other thing i want to do because we
talked about winning that election is i
want to raise more money for this party
than we've raised before specifically to
put fully paid campaign managers in all
our target seats because that's the
support that we need
[Applause]
good evening john good evening good
evening um
when we have a crisis of any sort in
this country
whether it's for us or anybody else we
normally appoint a task force
we have a
serious crisis going on with their
energy supplies and everything else
would you appoint a task force to
immediately if you become the prime
minister and actually see what they come
up with and um political direction
yes and you're right i mean
this task force approach has served us
well mostly with the facts actually and
the prime minister deserves enormous
credit for assembling that task force
empowering them and people like kate
kate bingham they did an extraordinary
job and i think all of us here feel very
proud
so
what what does that mean for energy well
it means it means a few things that we
need to get right i give you a few
things not only of course we need to
provide short-term support for people
but that's only term we need to make
sure we have to deal with this problem
again so we need better energy security
here at home reduce our energy
dependence so i want to absolutely
turbocharge our program of energy
efficiency because at the moment there
are millions of homes that can benefit
from loft insulation cavity wall
insulation smart controls we've got a
government set for money to do that but
it's not working properly and if we can
do that we can save people 400 pounds
off their bills and reduce our energy we
also need to create an innovation
economy that's going to knock a million
miles away from here create a small
modular reactors that can power all our
homes much more cheaply and cleanly we
need to find new forms of energy storage
to make sure that next year we don't
have to deal with this problem and
lastly we have to reform our energy
market now what i've been very clear
about is that we're all paying far too
much for our electricity at the moment
for reasons that we haven't addressed
because the electricity providers get to
charge us a very high price based on
what's going on in the natural gas
markets that's wrong i would change it
they've done it in lots of european
countries we're behind and as prime
minister i'd fix it so that you and all
the businesses can get cheaper
electricity as soon as possible because
that's what our country needs
a devastating effect in staffordshire
and
andrew stevenson's actually been to our
farm
i know farmers
that i've got have no income whatsoever
they've had land compulsory purchase
and yet they're not getting paid
they're getting no money we've been
waiting years for money to build a new
house
we're getting nothing
what are you going to do about it what
are you going to do about the effect on
staffordshire
and everywhere
i'm sorry to hear about your situation
and i'd be happy to talk to you office
make sure we get your situation resolved
as quickly as possible look on hs2 uh
that was a more negative reception about
hs2 than i expected given where we are
tonight but look
in general
i'm not going to be able to tell you
right now i can cancel that project i'm
not going to do that so we are where we
are at the moment now what i can tell
you though is and this actually goes to
your question is the company and andrew
will learn as well the company hs2
limited that is in charge of this needs
to be held to very further account
and that is something
and it's not just it's about making sure
that people like you are treated fairly
but it's also in general making sure
that disruption on communities is
absolutely minimized and whether it's
actually you know down down in the south
uh buckinghamshire where i was earlier
last week or up here at staffordshire we
need to make sure that as it's being
built it's being built in a way that
brings people uh along with them and
they deliver all the commitments that
they have made which clearly as far as i
can tell is not happening and i will fix
that as prime minister because that's
not right it's not fair and we need to
make sure that we correct it
[Applause]
thank you for joining us here today so
given the current um cost of living
crisis
and russia's part to play in that i was
wondering how are you going to tackle
our reliance on china
that's great that's a great question
so
china represents i believe the chinese
communist party represent the biggest
threat to our economic security and
thereby our national security
in the country right so that's a
straightforward fact
that's also what the head of mi5 and the
fbi recently said in a joint speech that
they gave so what does that mean for us
well it means we need to do a few things
we need to be robust in standing up for
our values
and our interests so it means supporting
people in hong kong as we so brilliantly
did recently
it means a defense partnership with
australia and america and putting our
aircraft carrier in the region to show
that we care about our allies over there
and it means what i do is chancellor
we're passing a new law that allows us
to block investment from hostile foreign
actors that are trying to infiltrate our
companies and steal our technology and
as prime minister i would use those
powers that i passed as chancellor to
make sure that we protect ourselves and
the last thing i say is we've got to be
thinking about the future threats right
now we are here in one of the most
amazing automotive manufacturing parts
of our country and over time we're going
to transition to electric vehicles that
will be great for net zero and create
lots of jobs and save us money but no
good us doing that if it turns out that
all the rare earth minerals going into
those batteries all come from china so
that's what i started doing as a chance
that was working with our allies like
australia canada america to build up the
supply chain
so exactly as you said means that we are
not relying on china in years to come
for things that are really important to
this country that's the type of thinking
that i think your prime minister needs
to have and that's the type of approach
to
china's response in support of ukraine
if it came to the point of a threat
physical threat a military threat on the
part of uh china towards taiwan
what should brings responsibility i i
wouldn't change our current policy on
that position at all
i think our policy previously taiwan is
the right one as it seems today
and concrete what would you do
military support the best thing we can
do to prevent aggression from against
taiwan from china is showing russia that
they will not be successful in ukraine
that is the absolute best thing we can
do
you leave it here
i know jackie gardner
do an awful lot of campaigning in
coventry trying to
get a conservative game so we do a lot
of knocking on doors and a lot of people
keep telling us
when we when we're going to sort out all
the immigration the illegal immigration
coming in so what would you do yes great
question
we should never lose sight of the fact
that our country has this unbelievable
capacity for compassion in welcoming
people from around the world my family
of beneficiary of that many others here
tonight would have also been and we've
demonstrated it
in hong kong in ukraine in afghanistan
and syria but when people are coming
here illegally it undermines trust in
the system we've got to grip it so we
have to be radical about it we have to
be bold if you've got five minutes
tonight alongside my contractor members
thing there's a ten point plan on this
that i put out because i think it is
genuinely one of the big emergencies
facing our countries there's a and you
can read about it here i'll give you one
or two specific bits of the ten point
plan to give you an illustration i want
to be different about this the first is
i want to move away from the european
definition of asylum because it is too
broad and it allows far too many people
second second thing and the second out
of the ten is we've got to get tougher
with our foreign policy so right now we
have this situation which is
extraordinary that we will go to a
country we'll talk to them about trading
we'll also give them
foreign aid right to help their country
but at the same time
we are not asking them or requesting
them or demanding that they also take
back their failed asylum seekers right
that's wrong
[Applause]
on this matter you said that the company
refused to take back deportees from this
country compared price in terms of aid
aid payments this country has as you
know a proud record for supporting
countries and peoples in need especially
and including humanitarian aid for
emergencies around the world are you
saying that aid will be in question
in the course of a dispute of this but
as i said specifically there's a
difference between humanitarian
emergencies which of course are always
going to be responsive to but then
situations where we have ongoing aid
programs in countries which we've had
for years and at the same time that
country is not taking back its failed
asylum seekers but i think that is a
practical common sense approach to this
problem and it's one that the vast
majority of the british people will
absolutely support and we should not be
shy
of policy
[Applause]
[Music]
there is always going to be more need
for our aid budget than we can provide
right that's just the fact sad fact but
that's reality of it so when we're
choosing where to provide aid who to
provide it to i think it is it's not my
money it's all your money the country's
money i think it's entirely reasonable
that if we're thinking about where we
can do that we do it with countries that
are happy to help us and take back their
fellow asylum seekers that seems
entirely logical and common sense to me
and i genuinely believe the vast
majority of the british public will be
quite surprised to find out that we
don't do that already quite frankly
[Applause]
and um party so what would you do if
you're an ex-prime minister following
from the amazing work that this trust
has done around the
script like solving it overnight and
protocol out and making sure that
northern ireland stays part of the union
yes so i would actually just carry on
with the policy that we've got in place
we haven't been in parliament that
you all know about i would carry that on
and you're right be in the sense that
northern ireland's economy is being
dragged out in the orbit of the uk and
that's wrong and the prime minister i
want to fix that and the bill gives us
the ability to do that uh if we can't
get a negotiated acceptance now the
other part you know we need to worry
about is obviously scotland and you
should mention but i think we might as
well talk about it for a second because
it's really important and now i think we
need to do a few things the first thing
is we've got to more actively
demonstrate the benefit of the union in
scotland and that's something that i
started doing as chancellor actually not
you know the civil service but all very
upset but i said we're going to actually
now start investing directly in scottish
communities but you know we're going to
talk to them directly and not have
everything just go to the smp government
because we believe in genuine evolution
that's really working and we need to do
more of that the second thing we need to
do is remember that when it comes to the
union in scotland who are we talking to
we're not talking to tories they're all
fine we need to talk to the third of the
people in scotland who do not vote
conservative and are never likely to but
are unionists right and you need a
leader who you think can actually talk
to those people right and i believe that
i can and the last thing is probably the
most important when it comes to arguing
for the union it's easy
to think about well there's what about
what you know made the argument hurt
borrowing how will scotland manage what
about their currency who's going to pay
their pensions what about trade but
those are all important arguments but we
have to remember
nationalism is very seductive it's a
romantic idea and we have to fight that
idea with an argument that speaks to
people's hearts and my grandparents
emigrated here not to england they
immigrated to the united kingdom and it
wasn't geography for them it represented
a set of values and we have to make an
argument about the union that is based
on those shared values that speaks to
the people's hearts and that's what i
will do as prime minister
would a trade war
with the european union because at the
moment european union london are at
loggerheads what a
at a time of recession be a price worth
paying
for making your points possible so
when you said rightly john that the
relationship is at loggerheads and i
think actually
think about this with a new prime
minister we have a chance to reset that
relationship because it's clear that
it's not in the best of places both in
france the eu with ireland now i believe
that as a new prime minister i will have
an opportunity to reset that
relationship i have very good relations
with all my counterparts in those places
and actually managed to get agreements
with them whether it's on sanctions
policy against russia or indeed on
global tax policy uh that shows that i
can constructively find solutions to
things so
i would like to bring that to the table
because if we can do that and reach a
negotiated solution it will be far
quicker in resolving the problems in
northern ireland than waiting for the
parliament which if necessary of course
i will do but will take time so i would
like to also try and pursue a negotiated
settlement and i think
there's an opening to try and do so
of course
[Applause]
any other answer
irresponsible but there is a danger of a
final trade economic conflict would that
be a price worth thinking
we're running out of time i'm going to
take one more question your questions
but look what we're talking about here
what we're talking about here is that if
your grandparent at the moment you can't
send a present to your granddaughter
from northern ireland from gb without
filling out a lot of forms if you want
to go camping you can't take your dog on
holiday right or if you're a british
supermarket and it's like i can't sell
my sandwiches in every part of the
united kingdom those are the kind of
practical things we're talking about no
one needs to have a trade war to resolve
practical things like that that's
completely ridiculous and we can find a
solution
let's go over here to this side three
rows four rows back with this arm here
can we go
ladies
let's do that first
hi so we've talked a lot over the last
month or so about employment and there
are lots of
professional sectors in the uk that we
struggle to
find in our staff for social workers
speech language therapists occupational
therapists all professions that are
highly skilled and have a real impact on
the health and safety of our children
and young people what are you going to
do to improve recruitment in those
sectors
well good question to end on and today
many of you here will have businesses
and i'm sure if i ask you what's the
number one challenge you have other than
energy bills i'm sure lots of you would
say it's getting workers right and that
is we all know lots of nodding right the
thing that's holding our economy back
and it's causing inflation at the moment
is a lack of people in the workforce so
i think we need to do a couple of things
and your question more broadly right the
first thing i want to do
is actually tackle our welfare system
and tighten it up because right now i'll
tell you this there are more people
claiming unemployment benefit
than there are job vacancies in the
economy right think about that that is
wrong it's certainly wrong under a
conservative government so i want to
make sure that we tighten up our welfare
system support people off benefits and
into work because that's good for them
good for their families good for the
taxpayer but also good for the economy
and will ease inflationary pressures and
it's exactly what a conservative
government should be doing
second thing
so second thing is obviously training
and skills and you mentioned social care
that one of the things that i was proud
to do even though it was difficult was
create a new way to fund the nhs and
social care and part of that money is
going to go to the social care workforce
because they don't feel appreciated or
valued enough and that's why lots of
them leave and we have high turnover
with the money we're going to create
career pathways new certification
training qualifications which will give
a real sense of career progression and i
know will mean that people stay in the
industry are more fulfilled will get
better care and will help with all the
recruitment issues and then the last
thing we need to do is be pragmatic on
migration right now i proudly voted for
brexit right and brexit for me was about
control of our borders it wasn't saying
that no one should ever come here right
so if we are tackling a legal migration
the ladies question we're doing that if
we are being tough on the welfare system
and getting people off that and into
work then i'm entirely pragmatic about
using migration where we need to to
support our public services or the
economy and i think many of us who voted
for brexit will be comfortable with that
as long as we're doing those other
things and that's the approach that i
will take to that problem
i'm literally shocked it's probably the
only hustings where we have not talked
about attacks
at the at the very very top i asked
about vac which was one of the tax
policies on your signature yeah i
we'll talk about corporation tax give me
your thoughts on your line on
corporation tax um well look
we're talking about big companies
right so
many of you
would have heard that i want to put up
corporation facts and i'm sure when liz
was here and she said she would scrap
that and you all probably clapped and
that's fine but let me explain why those
of you that are clapping are in my view
rock right let me explain what is
happening so yes corporation tax is
going to go up next year but
well it's going up in part because of
what i said because like margaret
thatcher and nigel wilson i believe it's
not right to have access and forward
right i don't think it's right to spend
money on public services and not pay for
it and ask our kids and our grandkids to
pick up the pack i don't think that's a
moral thing to do it's certainly
so
but
three things you need to know three
things about this that you need to know
right number one
we will still after this increase have
the lowest corporation tax rate in the
g7 so the large economies that we
compete against america canada germany
france italy japan we'll have the lowest
broaden it out to the 20 largest
economies in the world we compete
against we're gonna have the fourth
lowest grade so point number one this is
an internationally very low rate no one
can say otherwise right point number two
this only applies to the largest
businesses 70 of uk registered companies
won't pay the increase rate they're
exempt they're going to pay a small
profits rate because i want to support
small businesses my mom ran a small
business i know what it's like and we
are the party of small businesses that's
point number two right
point number three
now point number three and this is the
most important point right this is the
most important point
i'm going to combine that increase
with significant tax reforms and tax
cuts to the other bits of our corporate
tax system so for those businesses that
are invested so imagine that
manufacturing plant that's expanding
putting in an extra line putting in some
new robotics to increase the
productivity of its output that we have
a big tax cut for imagine another
business not a million miles away from
here that's investing in r d to create a
new small modular reactor that's going
to provide clean energy for us at
affordable prices or anything else that
business also is going to get a tax cut
on r d why
because those are the areas
where we fall behind all our other
countries when you say why is our
productivity
lower why is our growth not as high it's
because our businesses are not investing
as much they're not innovating as much
i've studied this problem i've talked to
a million people i've got a career in
business and i know what will work
and if we deliver these tax cuts because
i'm a conservative like you i want to
cut taxes and i think tax cuts hand
drive growth but only if we cut the
right ones and with my plan we will
actually get the outcome we want if we
go with liz's plan and stick with what
we've done for the last 10 years
nothing's going to change investment in
this country today no higher than it was
a decade ago we've got to try something
different my plan is a better plan and
i'm 100
convinced that if you give me this job
and we deliver this tax plan we will
have a faster growing higher
productivity economy that is creating
jobs everywhere but especially here
so we are
the signature policy attacks between the
two sides and two candidates in this
this race to be our next next prime
minister we made some progress i think
in in learning a few things that perhaps
we haven't learned until this moment we
shall see that two weeks still to go it
is still not over a lot of people still
vote even though a lot of you seem to
have done so for now this evening let's
hope you found that and listen there's
some times where you
found a useful exercise as well thanks
to our candidates thanks to you and for
me a very good night